[Music]
every little thing
you think that you need every little
thing you think that you need
every little thing that's just feeding
your greed oh i bet that you'll be fine
without it
[Music]
hello everybody welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less
my name is joshua fields milburn and i'm
ryan nicodemus and together we are the
minimalists
welcome to episode number 60.
today number 60 already 6-0
the 50s flew by the 40s flew by now
we're at number 60 and today
we are going to talk about money money
money money
money sean's looking up he was like oh
my god are the ojs in the room right now
we're gonna talk about
uh finances today it's gonna really
round out i think what
is gonna end up being the trilogy of of
money related
finance related podcast so a while ago i
think it was episode
i'm trying to think back into my memory
banks episode number 12
was about money and then episode 28
was about debt and so what we're going
to do today
it'll be about 80 new stuff that we're
talking about today there will obviously
be some overlap with the money and debt
episodes we've got some new questions
and some hopefully some new answers as
well that's what we're going to be
talking about today
before we dive in ryan i wanted to do a
few things
uh first off i wanted to mention that we
are hitting the road pretty soon
we're going to bring an in-depth talk
about minimalism
to your city but we're also going to do
a live version of
this podcast in your city as long as
that city is one of the cities we are
going to
it's called the less is now tour and our
first city is going to be
boston on april 15th at the wilbur
theater that one is almost
sold out but there are still some
tickets left other cities are going to
be added really soon
if you're on our email list over at
theminimalists.com you'll be the first
to know about new
cities new tour dates and you can find
all those cities at the minimalists.com
tour also before we before we jump in
the deep end here ryan
our friend david friedlander wrote an
article
not too long ago sort of about economics
quite often we'll get
we'll get this argument about minimalism
is for
privileged people or minimalism is for
rich people which is
is always shocking to me when i hear
this because and it's shocking to me
because you and i have
we grew up really poor and we knew we
could have benefited from minimalism
then
we've met hundreds if not thousands of
people
who who are certainly making below the
poverty line in terms of income who have
benefited from minimalism
we've met plenty of rich people who have
benefited from minimalism
as well so david friedlander in response
to some
a new york times article that came out
last year he
he wrote a really articulate response
but it has a lot to do with
with economics or the economy or the
economics of minimalism
and i was hoping to read that and we
could kind of start off with um
a discussion about that and and what
your thoughts are
on some of his points so this is by
david friedlander who
many of you would know from our
documentary minimalism a documentary
about the important things he was
interviewed along with his wife
jacqueline and and
their two kids well they had one kid but
then she was pregnant at the time
and they were in their beautiful
minimalist apartment in
new york anyway this article ryan it's
called
minimalism class fetishes
and the fate of the planet and sean if
you would
please put that a link to this in the in
the show notes or
ryan as a as a reader pointed out
recently maybe we should call them the
sean notes because i'm so often telling
sean to put something in
the shawn notes i don't know if that one
will stick but
uh yeah we'll put a link to this article
in the show notes
over the last several years news outlets
and the new york times in particular
have portrayed the minimalist
movement in myriad ways as a fetishistic
fad a type of blindness for the well to
do
a source of liberation these often
contradictory views
are perhaps reflective of a societal
confusion
people so long economical economically
and emotionally
enmeshed with their stuff might not know
what to think of minimalism
does it have substance is it something
that will seem as ridiculous tomorrow as
the macarena
does today the macarena does seem a
little bit ridiculous now doesn't it
i love the macarena well yeah you just
go to weddings just for the macarena
it's the only dance i know how to do
well
well that i mean i see you do the
electric slide all the time
you've never seen me do the electric
sled well well
that's true all right to make sense of
the subject let's discuss some of the
criticisms
of the minimalism movement and let's see
if it's something we should be paying
attention to
and then he has a section here called
minimalism throughout history
prior to the era of cheap industrially
manufactured
consumer good plentitude there was a
term for
minimalism it was called
life in this era which encompasses all
but the last 70 years or so of human
existence
people used what they needed and
oftentimes a lot less
because manufacturing technology was
primitive
stuff was labor intensive to make
and therefore expensive to buy to
illustrate
the bureau of labor statistics found
that a
household in 1900 so what is that ryan a
hundred and
17 years ago man you are so good at math
hey sean can we put the instead of under
health can we file this podcast under
[Music]
math
anyway um great idea let's see uh he
says a household at 1900
spent listen to this ryan they spent 50
percent of their budget on
food and clothing half the money that
the average
household made spend half their money on
clothes and
food so socks were darned bacon grease
was kept in a tin can by the stove
my mom did that when we were growing up
i don't know if yeah i bet your parents
said
at some point yeah uh kept by a tin can
uh
in a tin can by the stove and so forth
other stuff was really expensive too
there were things like radio repair
shops
because one-click shopping had not been
invented yet do you remember radio shack
i do man i saw this amazing uh it was a
meme
where it was a flyer of radio shack and
had like all these different devices on
there
and literally like the meme was every
single thing
in this you know 1988 version of radio
shack
is on your cell phone now oh wow it was
all combined into a cell phone you know
it's interesting so so
bex and i have been watching we tend to
pick like one tv show to watch and we'll
watch like one episode a week or so
and the one we've been watching we're
way way behind the times
uh is the americans do you know about
the show
it's it's really really good so far it
took me about three episodes to really
get sucked into it but now i'm in their
world and it takes place in the 80s but
it is like a pristine
version of americana in the 80s and you
and i were both born in 1981 and we we
grew up in the 80s
and i remember you know like the the the
buicks and the chevys the
these big cars with v8 engines and like
all of the accoutrements of the 80s the
the walkmans
and the uh record players and and and
the things that
that added value to my life at one point
they've become obsolete and and and i
think the problem with a lot of what
we're holding on to these days and this
is a total tangent but
we're we're swimming around in
obsolescence
and it's and i really like the thing he
talks about here like the
the there used to be radio repair shops
you and i wouldn't even think about
repairing a radio
now i remember uh last week i in fact
backs her
she has has this i don't know 10 year
old 15 year old radio
but has an adapter plugged into us so we
can listen to
to you know an ipod or whatever with via
bluetooth
it has an auxiliary yeah plug-in or
something yeah and it just
it stopped working and my first thought
was like oh no now we have to buy a new
one because there isn't
a a radio recorder although
i still see some places like the vacuum
repair store so there's still some
places or there's still handymen who
will help you well yeah i mean
to me it's like it comes down to like
the cost of a new thing right the
new radio is going to cost you 50 bucks
like you can get a
remember i don't know if you remember
like the i don't i don't even want to
throw a
brand name out there because like like
jl or i don't i don't want to do
something but
yeah yeah there were those radios where
it was like this five-disc
cd changer oh man and then like the big
speakers like the one on either side of
it yeah you can get one of those for
like 120 bucks i mean now those are like
50 bucks
yeah if they even make them anymore at
some point because so so few
manufacturers will make
make them even it'll it'll be they'll
actually the price will go up eventually
um if you really want something like
that the 100 disc
cd changer is irrelevant right but
at least for most of us i mean it may
not be for other for some people some
people
i was listening to uh henry rollins
recently uh bex and i saw him live
and when we were in la but he was on the
joe rogan podcast recently and
he has a crazy stereo system that he
absolutely
loves i mean it's he doesn't own much
he's he
i would consider him to be a minimalist
the way he was talking but he has this
stereo system and he loves listening to
vinyl and
he just turns it up halfway because the
speakers he has these
they're probably ten thousand dollar
speakers or something i have no idea
what speakers cost these days
but he has these really expensive
speakers all he has to do is turn it up
not even halfway and you get all the
nuance
well i'm thinking of podcast shawn who's
wearing his new headphones now
and he was talking about how he was
listening to i don't know
what it was an abba album maybe uh i
think you could go back to abba oh is it
ava
tomato i mean some people's i mean i
guess it's
but yeah no one says tomorrow all right
he was listening to a toto
album yes
um do you own one toto album
not just one
it's like pringles you can't you can't
just listen to one toto album
anyway he was listening to to this toto
album and
he he could um make out the brush
strokes
on the drums and sean's a drummer um and
and so like
yeah he was really enthusiastic about
because he got these new headphones and
they work
really really well and and and my point
is that
the technology can enhance our lives but
at some point if it becomes obsolete
we either need to be willing to repair
it or let it go and obsolete for you
maybe
not may not be obsolete for obsolete for
me
and i think this is an important part of
this finances discussion because part of
can i afford this thing also means can i
afford maintaining it
am i going to use this longer term or is
it a temporary solution i'm going to
have to replace it a month from now
and so i'm going to get back to this
essay here uh he says other stuff was
really expensive too there were things
like radio repair shops because
one-click
shopping had not yet been invented
and then he has a picture here of this
house right i'll flip my my screen
around it's just a husband and his wife
and their
horse and buggy so man look at those
hipsters
yeah i think this is this photo was
taken in brooklyn last week
anyway um anyway there's a horse and
buggy there
and it's another thing like the horse
and buggy is still
a thing but on a much more limited scale
than it once was it's not our main means
of of transportation i would argue that
the majority of horse and buggy
situations now are novelty
absolutely racing yeah like nostalgic
value uh
yeah anytime you see a horse carriage
ride through the city it's like a big
deal like
right this is what they used to do 100
years ago exactly everyone was in a
horse carriage
yeah it was it was a normal thing and i
think our cars will eventually be that
way where it's
it's you're not going to be driving the
car yourself you're not going to be an
ape
behind the steering wheel because it's
no longer going to be safe at some point
there's 30 000 people who die every year
in the united states
uh over a million people die a year in
in
the world a million people if we can
save the vast majority of those people
it's going to make sense to move on
but there will still be tracks that you
can go to where you can race your
your your own car or your car or rent a
car to race and
and that will be fun for the day but
it's not going to be your primary means
of transportation this is a great
business idea
[Laughter]
anyway i'll get back to the essay here
he said world war ii represented a
quantum leap in manufacturing efficiency
which is true because you know as stuff
was
was required to be made we ramped up
manufacturing big time
he said suddenly stuff was being made
with a fraction
of the previous labor and expense by
1950
food and clothes so just 50 years later
had dropped to
only 42 percent of household
expenditures and would continue
to plummet with more disposable income
and enormous
industrial capacity at our command we
started making
non-essential stuff and i think this is
the transition the post-world war ii
transition we started making
non-essential stuff
perfect to fill the suburban
single-family homes
that were becoming the archetypical
american
housing setup so think about that for a
moment we are building bigger houses
and we talked about this on our last
episode with the
the the housing the home the episode on
home episode number 58
we we talk about you know just because
we have a huge space
a 4 000 square foot foot home doesn't
mean we have to fill it with stuff but
of course manufacturers
and people then accordingly we're like
well i've got this big house
i'm gonna have to fill it with stuff and
then manufacturers like it's not some
conspiracy or like oh we're gonna
make people build bigger houses so we
can sell them more stuff no it's
it's part of the human condition we have
more space to fill so we try to fill it
right
and david says but there was a problem
you can only make so much stuff paying
the fair wages most americans expected
so someone had the brilliant idea to
combine
post-world war ii american industrial
know-how
with dirt cheap overseas labor the us
once the making stuff capital of the
world
according to derek thompson of the
atlantic experienced a
precipitous decline in its manufacturing
might and you know we're seeing that now
i mean you and i uh spent most of our
time in in and around
dayton ohio manufacturing town was once
called little detroit because that was
a compliment because detroit was this
booming city in the 50s and dayton was a
small version of that
and now it's very much like little
detroit you go downtown dayton which is
where i once lived
you you see 65
of the buildings there are vacant there
are entire skyscrapers
that have no tenants but they're just
standing there like remnants of
of the past they've become obsolete in
in a way
and so uh let's see back to back to the
text here
the upshot of this decline was access to
abundant and cheap consumer goods
in 2000 we spent only 20 percent
of our household income on clothes and
food so 100 years later we went from
spending half our income
to only one-fifth on closing food wow so
less than half the amount
than just 50 years before clothing
dropped get this this was the most
staggering part to me clothing dropped
to 4 of our expenses even though
the volume of our clothes has gone up
considerably right i mean it's much
greater i mean you got to think in 1900
people owned their three outfits or two
outfits that they had really
well fast fashion didn't exist in 1900
right right
fast fashion you know was three months
to make your shirt
yeah it's like hurry up i'll make it in
two that's fast fashion right
uh but yeah it didn't it didn't exist
and and
same went for food we're we're spending
less on on on eating
but we're actually eating more as a
society right
wow fast fashion and fast food yeah
and so the next section here is the
democracy of
consumerism in her recent new york times
editorial the class
politics of decluttering stephanie land
suggests
as other times writers have before that
minimalism
is the privilege of the elite for whom
stuff
is easily bought and discarded depending
on one's mood
she writes about a minimalism
documentary
where quote bad
consumption is portrayed by masses of
people swarming into big box stores on
black friday
slaves to material goods versus
minimalists who
are quote independent thinkers free to
enjoy the higher planes of life
and then she goes on to say that those
people flocking to walmart are
purchasing furniture
or an entertainment set or a television
bigger than the
average amer average computer monitor
on sale because these things would
otherwise be beyond their means
the implication being that these are
things
rich folks don't think twice about
buying so it's easy and hypocritical to
judge the poor
mobs for fighting over stuff the rich
consider birthrights i
i'll step back for a second on black
friday i mean you and i
when we've talked about this before in
our holiday episode
with respect to black friday and um you
and i worked in retail for a long time
and i could tell you that the people who
show up on black friday are all over
the social economic spectrum most of
them are middle class
most are middle class people the vast
majority are middle class or in many
cases they're the ones that can afford
to go and spend like their hundred
dollars that they spend on a thing is
going to go further
at on black friday so they can get more
stuff for their 100 bucks right
it's not poor people showing up with
pennies in their pockets
buying a big screen tv because that's
the only time they can afford it
you and i never participated in black
friday as kids we couldn't afford it my
mom could barely keep the
in fact often wasn't able to keep the
electricity on and so
no we're not going out on on some sort
of black friday sale holiday we didn't
have the money to do that and and so
i think it's absurd but i can tell you
who did do it well i i had ants who were
were rich or at least upper middle class
and they it was a sport for them to go
out on black friday
so middle class or upper middle class
because they enjoyed you know the
the sort of hunt part of that and now it
actually seems
i mean when you see the the footage in
our documentary people literally
trampling other people it feels like a
weird sort of
dystopian kind of hunting yeah in a way
and so no you're right it is mostly
middle-class people we saw coming into
our stores on black friday when you and
i manage a bunch of retail stores
it was they were middle class no it
wasn't someone coming it wasn't a you
know someone coming in with their family
of seven
who hasn't been able to afford a cell
phone all year and they're like oh thank
you for having this sale and
we could finally afford this this one
day of the year right it's yeah it was
uh i
i never saw that um i'm not saying that
that doesn't exist
um but yeah i think that that argument
is kind of yeah it certainly exists
it certainly exists but but but it's
certainly not exclusive
to people who are low income right and
and
uh what i noticed going through the the
the
black fridays of of yesteryear is that
it affected everyone on the
socio-economic spectrum and that
just because you're a middle class
didn't mean you're uh immune to
to making bad decisions right and so
but you're also not immune to making
good decisions there were a lot of
middle class people who came into our
stores
who were living beyond their means and
so even though they
made decent money they spent even more
money than that and so they had a lot of
debt and they were figuring out i mean
like plenty of people who you you were
shocked when their credit card got
declined but because they were living
beyond their means as was i and as were
you at one point we were
living even though we made good money we
spent even better money
and uh so back to the article here she
says the implication being
or he's what he's saying the implication
being that these things
rich folks don't think twice about
buying so it's easy and hypocritical to
judge the poor mobs for fighting over
stuff the rich consider birthrights
it's a logical narrative but one that
doesn't accord with reality
david says all right moving on here as
the
times annie laurie reported a couple
years ago
the cost of retail goods has dropped
precipitously in the last 10 years
it has created what economists call the
walmart effect
which virtually anything produced in a
factory
can be bought at bargain prices rich and
poor
people alike are drowning in stuff
and to me that is the key takeaway here
from our society rich and poor people
alike are drowning in stuff working off
data from the bureau of labor statistics
lowry reported that poverty
is a function of low wages and
factors such as housing health care
child care and education not
consumer goods so just to sum that up
poverty
while consumer goods might be certainly
be a part of it and decisions we make
with that
it based on the bureau of labor
statistics poverty has a lot more to do
with the low
low wages that we have and then housing
health care child care all these other
expensive things education
this focus on class obscures the main
point of minimalism and that's really
what i wanted to get to right here
with this finances episode it doesn't
really matter where you are in the
social
economic spectrum we can spin the
resources we have
more responsibly and so stripped of its
formal slash
aesthetic construct minimalism's message
is this
you probably don't need that that
could be a new gadget or nana's quilt
taking up space in the basement
of the too large home you pay a mortgage
on you don't need it
if you have the money and you definitely
don't need it if you don't
the stuff won't make you happy and
chances are good
that it will distract you from the parts
of your life that do
as dave bruno wrote stuff is not passive
and here's my favorite line from the
article
stuff wants your time attention and
allegiance
i think that's really important our
stuff wants our time it wants our
attention it wants our allegiance
but you know it as well as i do life is
more important than the things we
accumulate the guys behind the movie
that's us
hey that is us the guy's behind the hey
where are those guys
uh eludes uh uh
the guys behind the movie that the
writer alludes to joshua fields milburn
and ryan nicodemus aka the minimalist
both come from dirt poor homes we were
broke this is a quote i think from
me we were broke that broke food stamps
and wick and various other forms of
intermittent government assistance
joshua fields milburn said their
respective
origin stories involve a pursuit and
eventual attainment of
money and material wealth by age 19 i
was making over 50
000 a year twice as much as i'd ever
seen mom bring home but i was
spending even more racking up credit
card debt i obviously needed
the three m's in my life make more money
milburn said he and nicodemus traveled
the well-trodden path
toward happiness via professional
advancement
leading to increased stories of stuff
and increased overhead
debt and stress and they also found out
that that path
led nowhere something incidentally the
times documented a few years ago
and the op-ed piece living with less a
lot less by graham hill
who's also on our documentary while the
devotees of marie kondo might suggest
minimalism is a patrician dalliance
there are plenty of people like
milburn and nicodemus who came from
modest means
people who arrive at minimalism after
bottoming out on the pursuit of
actualization
through accumulation and then he put
this like this
photo in here you got to see it ryan
it's uh it's an onion
cover this is the top 10 products to
battle consumerism
oh wow and and that that's where we
always have to be you know skeptical
right the onion is fake news just for
those who aren't aware
yeah i think it i thought it was
alternative news
[Music]
and and yes kyle shaka writes the
oppressive gospel of minimalism
minimalism can be culturally
appropriated by wealthy folks
first time something like that's
happened eh is what david wrote here
it can take on a dwell magazine
slash a moma store sheen that obscures
the essence of the movement
which is all about intentional
subtraction
there are no purchases necessary to be a
minimalist and it's a good idea to be
suspicious of anyone
that says there are and i think that's
that was the
the the great way and he he goes on even
farther
here about um the biggest reason to go
minimal but i'd like to
pause for a second just say yeah let's
be suspicious here there are tools
that will add value to your life their
books and our documentary
and uh joshua becker and leo babalta's
blogs and courtney carver and her
uh simple year course there are things
that can help you
sure but just don't think that you have
to have anything
to simplify your life yeah i promise
yeah anyone listening to this right now
i promise you uh if you have a million
dollars in the bank there isn't like
this magic
thing that you can buy that's going to
help you do the work right
yeah yeah and the same thing the you
might find enlightenment in a particular
book or
going back all the way to the stoics and
reading some of that stuff those are
experiences
and i think that's nice but don't think
you need a thing to simplify your life i
think it's one of the bigger problems
with places like the container store
people think they go there i'm gonna buy
a bunch of things to organize my life
well that's
part of the problem the organizing is
inherently problematic
and so david here sums it up and says
the biggest reason to go minimal
the talk of class politics and
fetishization of minimalism
i got that word right first time i i
just
was reading it right here i'm like i'm
not going to get the word fetishization
right the first time i read it but there
you go
but there i i thought it was earlier in
the like in the very beginning of the
essay maybe
anyway he he said something else at the
beginning he said
uh it wasn't fetishization
he said fetishistic fad
fetishistic and then i followed it up
with my perfect execution of fetishes
[Laughter]
you couldn't blame this folks the the
talk of class politics and fetishization
of minimalism
misses the biggest point one that makes
all those
topics seem trivial the planet is being
ruined
in our pursuit of more a journal of
industrial
ecology study from earlier this year
found
household consumption is quote
responsible for
up to 60 percent of global greenhouse
gas emissions and between 80
or 50 to 80 percent of total land
material and water use that's staggering
the initiative and so for me and and
i've said this before but
it's worth noting here for me
environmentalism wasn't the the core
benefit
of embracing a minimalist lifestyle but
it was a really nice benefit if you
consume less you produce
less waste so even if you're not
concerned about the environment
then you're still helping the
environment by producing less waste
you're helping other other people as
well
even if you don't even if you don't buy
into that you don't believe in in
climate change or whatever
producing less waste is still a good
thing everyone
i think everyone can get on board with
that right um
okay and then let's see here uh an
initiative called
earth overshoot day calculated that on
august 8 2016 we began to use
more from nature than our planet can
renew in the whole year
if we are to even dream of keeping the
planet habitable
david writes we must stop consuming so
much stuff
you can argue that holding on to excess
old stuff
shares much of the blame with the new
stuff and i thought this was an
interesting point ryan
holding on to the stuff shares part of
the blame right the infrastructure for
storing our stuff
our humongous suburban homes the 22
billion dollar storage
industry we support our resource
hungry by-products of our inabilities to
let
go of stuff so we're we're
facing other problems by our inability
to let go what minimalism does
is makes this ecological imperative a
choice rather than an
imposition and i think that's the
important part often we'll hear people
yeah i was forced to become a minimalist
well no minimalism is
about intentionality you can't be forced
into being intentional
i was forced into meditating that's not
meditation
right now you may your circumstances may
force you to be more deliberate with the
resource you have and i i think
that deliberate use is great i'm sorry
if
some situation forced you into becoming
more of a a
a intentional person but i'm grateful
for that outcome if you are becoming
more intentional regardless of your
resources and so
it says don't be afraid of having less
because
it's pretty great that's what he's
saying about minimalism minimalism says
don't be afraid of having less
because it's pretty great and it's not a
bs message either ample research attests
that
the best things in life aren't things
and here's a link to the research there
that relationships and rich experiences
and expressing gratitude for what we
have
are the hallmarks of a good life and
stuff
whether it's a new iphone or your spoon
collection
is just stuff minimalism can be seen
as a realignment of priorities and a
preparation
for a world when we cannot have
everything we need when we want it
but minimalism is not an act of
sacrifice
or rather it's no more of a sacrifice
than removing
a malignant tumor sure it hurts at first
but it's really good for you to let you
live a lot longer
and happier life you won't
miss it i don't even pay attention to
that i mean this it was a beautiful
article but like honestly like i
hate i hate um reading an article that
is arguing another article because at
the end of the day there is no argument
against
minimalism it i mean at this point for
me it should be an a political issue
i totally agree with it it's like it is
a yeah the world is
suffering uh because of our consumption
habits here
in this country yeah and the western
world yeah there are third world
countries who
i mean kids are literally left on the
street to die yeah
and i'm not saying that like you know
someone
consuming fast fashion like that's a
direct result
but uh it certainly is a byproduct of
our consumption
yes and uh yeah it's it's uh there is no
there is no good argument against
minimalism like to me
the articles written are oh well it's
easy for you to say because you've been
rich
whether you were poor or not you've been
rich so you can say that money doesn't
buy happiness
money doesn't buy happiness has been
thousands of years old
yes that that that saying that advice is
thousands of years old
and no matter what no matter how you
rebuttal that
it's always going to be something that
we hear growing up
money doesn't buy happiness so uh
yeah it's it's um yeah it's a great
article i mean yeah he did such an
awesome job of of kind of rebutting that
stuff but
when i hear stuff like that all i all i
can really hear is
um i want money so i can decide for
myself
and sure like that attitude is that is
going to be
um well that's just not going to
aid in living a meaningful life totally
agree with that i i hope what this
article accomplishes for some people
is someone who says i'm not willing to
give minimalism chance because i'm not
rich
at least give it a chance but see that
but i would argue that that person
doesn't want to give minimalism a chance
period
right right i i think in most cases
that's probably true they're using that
as an excuse
right for why they don't want to give it
and it's not i mean even if you could
show them a minimalistic life like they
are
and i don't know how to move people past
that point uh-huh i mean this is what we
try to do every single day i don't have
like a magic bullet answer to move
people past that point but anyone who
has that argument
is it's a lame argument yeah and i think
i think the best way to move people past
is you and i
have seen you're right there is not this
silver bullet where you're like
here here's your answer here are the
three steps it's
uh the people who thought we were crazy
when you and i first embraced minimalism
seven years ago or whatever that was
eight years ago uh for me
it it people thought i was crazy thought
i was suicidal because i was getting rid
of stuff
and it took them years to come around
because they saw the benefits and and
they realized like
oh josh has distanced himself from this
discontented life
and move to a life that is more
contented and i had to leave some people
behind in the process
i tried to drag a few of them kicking
and screaming toward a simpler life
and realized that didn't work and and
the best way to get them to follow you
is actually have them follow you
if that's what they choose to do right
and so no it's not everyone is going to
embrace minimalism
tomorrow and not everyone's going to
embrace minimalism period
but hopefully hopefully if if you feel
that there is some barrier for you
realize that there isn't
and and whether that's your finances or
some other barrier of people in your
life whatever
there aren't like ryan said there aren't
really good excuses
there and by the way if they're if you
think you have a really good excuse
it's still an excuse at the end of the
day
and so uh today let's let's move on
let's let's talk about some finances
we've got some questions to
to answer here hey before we go to this
voicemail i do just want to say
like i would josh i would never ever
tell anyone no matter where they fall on
the socio-economic scale
that they couldn't uh they couldn't live
a good life by living more deliberately
or by living deliberately not even more
deliberately
right i mean i would never tell anyone
no matter where they fall on the
socio-economic scale that they couldn't
uh benefit from living a deliberate life
yeah i think i think it's disempowering
first of all
i mean and it's in unbeknownst to people
who write articles like that that
you know will talk about how well you
know minimalism doesn't work for poor
people
they are discriminating against poor
people yeah like what are they whether
they know it or not like they are
inadvertently
discriminating against poor people
saying that oh well this would never
work for you because you don't have
money yeah i mean how that i wouldn't
that's horrible man yeah i totally agree
so speaking of money let's talk about
how we can get our our finances
in order our first question is from john
in chicago
i'm a physician have a host
of uh of school debt um
around two hundred thousand dollars i
think just shy of two hundred thousand
dollars i think it's around 180 000
um plus about 40
000 in credit card debt uh through a
number of poor choices i've made
throughout my life
i've been whittling away at it um but at
the same time i'm also self-employed and
looking to start building up for
retirement my question is the following
with such significant credit card debt
uh 40 to 45 000 in credit card debt
some with aprs you know 10 11
15 16 does it make sense to be putting
away
for retirement when the return
on that investment is going to be so
significantly
or excuse me going to be significantly
smaller
in the short term or should all of my
time and attention and finances
basically
be put towards paying off my credit
cards down to zero as fast as possible
i had been previously saving
twenty percent of all of my paychecks
especially since i'm self-employed to
uh cover uh taxes at the end of the year
but what i realized was i was putting
this money in my savings account
and i was getting no value but i was
being charged uh you know 11 to
16 percent on this credit card debt
which was taking probably more than i
was saving
so i started i took the money out of my
savings i have a
enough for a rainy day about a thousand
two different accounts
it's around 2000 and i've been trying to
just
radically pay down as much of my credit
card debt as fast as possible
i would love to know your opinion about
this and maybe
just a general assessment or a general
idea of where do you prioritize your
finances i know
always safe retirement i know always
have some
for a rainy day but when you're replaced
with
you know credit card debt with large
percentages
should all of our resources time and
energy be
put towards paying that down as soon as
possible
in the short term and then really
ramping up
the savings after that john
my friend when you told us at the very
beginning about your student debt you
said
i got about 200 000 in student debt i
don't know maybe about 180.
this is a red flag for me yeah 180 000
is the same to you as 200 000 that's a
20 000 difference that's a that's a
brand new hyundai
like that is a that's a lot of money man
so
i think getting your head around exactly
what you owe
uh starting with that budget i mean you
know when you look at the minimalist.com
freedom the number one step on there to
financial freedom is is getting a budget
yeah not knowing exactly what your debts
are giving or taking twenty thousand
dollars that to me is a red flag
so i would just get clear on that i'm
not saying that like you're going about
this wrong way or anything like that i'm
not even trying to make you feel bad i'm
just
trying to move you to be uh to have a
better idea of what your debts are
um how much you're paying off each month
what those balances are every month
i think that's important and like you
said the budget is a first step so what
what ryan's referencing here
is an essay that we wrote last year it's
called financial freedom
five difficult steps to get out of debt
create a simple budget
plan for the future and regain control
of your finances
the key word in that whole title there's
two of them ryan freedom
and difficult yeah man yeah because this
is simple advice whoa get a budget
really simple advice yeah and well it's
a hard it's hard advice when you got to
put a budget together for
200 000 worth of debt or is it 180 we're
not sure right
and then he also mentioned 40 about 40
000
in credit card debt so so getting when
you're getting that together
i want you to know that you have 41
318 dollars and 46 cents
in credit card debt and because i want
you to feel that pain that's how you're
going to make
a significant change here is if you can
feel the pain it reminds me of this
thing that seth godin wrote very
recently ryan really short essay
he said it's almost impossible to sell
the future
if you're trying to persuade someone to
make an investment buy some insurance or
support a new plan
please consider that human beings are
terrible at
buying these things and he said what
we're good at
is now right now yeah when we buy a
stake in the future
what we're actually buying is how it
makes us feel today
we move up all all the imagined benefits
and costs of something in the future and
experience them
right now that's why it's hard to stick
to a diet because
celery tastes bad today i kind of like
celery it's not bad
it's got a lot of fiber in it right i
think so yeah yeah and no calories
that's such a good i have not read that
i say that is such a good point
uh so it's because celery tastes bad
today and we can't
easily experience feeling healthy
in 10 years like we can't experience
that
future self right that's why we make
such dumb financial decisions too
because it's so tempting to believe
magical stories about tomorrow that's
how you see the
the lottery winner on on tv or whatever
and you're like oh that could be me now
if you want to buy a lottery ticket i'm
not going to yell at you for that if
you're in debt i think it's a stupid
thing to do
a really stupid thing to do yeah and
maybe like
you know 99 of the time that's the
stupid thing to do but maybe like that's
your only entertainment
one dollar you spend right on the
powerball each week it's four dollars a
month
yeah still probably not the best use of
the money but it's still a terrible use
of your money i just don't want to make
people feel better than buying they're
buying a lottery ticket it is better
than buying
yeah i don't know man i mean what kind
of drugs are we talking about
if you want people to be smarter or more
active or more generous about their
future
you'll need to figure out how to make
the transaction about how it feels
right now and so john what i want you to
do you need to associate more pain with
this debt man you're feeling it you're
feeling a little bit of pain i know it's
overwhelming
but you as ryan said with that budget
man that budget is gonna help you
feel some of that pain yeah step number
one cut up your credit cards maybe
you've done that already but anyone out
there right now who is
in credit card debt and they still have
credit cards yeah
cut them up or at least put a little
note on the back of the card that's like
hey every time you spend this you are
you are
uh basically taking out a 16 loan which
is i mean that's
i want to say that's worse than like a
uh like a
a payday come here now cash your check
it's not but it's pretty i mean
i mean it's close to like i mean maybe
that's a little bit worse but i mean
it's just as bad i guess is what i'm
saying they're both horrible decisions
horrible horrible decisions it's like
you're going out to a meal
and let's say that you're like oh you
know what like i know i don't have the
money in my account but i'll just pay
this hundred dollars from my credit card
you're not paying a hundred dollars
you're paying 116 right and then if you
don't pay that 116 bucks off the
following
month well then you're paying an
additional 16 so it would basically be
like you going to a restaurant them
saying hey we'll go and give you this
meal now at a 16
interest rate if that's how the waiter
pitched it to you
yeah you'd probably say no yeah or if
you're like hey how much is this ten
dollar meal
um it's it's eleven dollars and fourteen
cents wait a minute
wait wait a minute uh plus tax and and
so
it's so it's uh i think dave ramsey
calls it a stupid tax
uh paying interest on your credit cards
you're paying the stupid tax
and so yeah let's talk about the budget
real quick since you brought that up
ryan so
so the first thing we talk about and
again you can find all this at the
minimalist.com
freedom or in the show notes to this
episode uh we talk about breaking things
into categories
the need want like list you want to
write down every expense that you have
whether it's your food your housing your
utilities your insurance
health insurance your car or cars
gas your transportation your clothes
your credit card your phone bills your
internet bill
your pets uh entertainment yeah every
everything that you have your
your um uh lottery tickets everything
you're spending money on right
and and triple check that list with your
significant other or friend or family
member
make sure that you have everything on
that list in those three categories
and i won't go into detail on how you
differentiate between need want and like
you can read all the details there
and then the second thing you want to do
with a budget is you want to give
yourself some boundaries you need to
give
every dollar a destination at the
beginning of a month
by establishing these boundaries you
won't you really won't worry about
what you can and can't purchase because
the money at the beginning of the month
is already assigned at the beginning of
the month so it can't be spent mid-month
it already has
a home throughout the month and so you
you won't have any extra money for that
another thing i do with those boundaries
i with that money i i assigned to
different places when i was getting out
of debt
and i'd do the like the envelope system
or whatever um
i would i would make sure that i
couldn't
i could rob from one envelope to pay
another but that was it
so so do i want to not have food later
this month if so i could buy a new pair
of jeans that's a
decision i had to make i just wasn't
going to get into any more debt
and that's another thing we didn't even
talk about at this point right but he
has to we sort of talked about with the
credit card thing
he has to agree not to get any more debt
i understand why you got into student
loan debt and you're
you're a physician uh which means you
know which means you're a rich person so
minimalism will work for you
uh no but you're a physician and you're
not a rich person you're broke
you are freaking broke so minimalism
won't work for him then oh
man cause he's broke it won't work yeah
uh so i'm gonna i'm gonna i'm gonna go
off on a tangent here a different essay
here
11 signs you might be broke this is also
on our website we'll put a link to it in
the show notes
you might be this is like the the jeff
foxworthy you might be a redneck
you might be a bro might be a minimalist
if patent that's a good one that'd be a
good one too yeah
someone writes that uh tweet us anyway
uh you might be broke if number one you
are living paycheck to paycheck which
john you certainly are doing
if you're spending every dollar you take
home you are by definition broke
more than 75 of americans are living
paycheck to paycheck
with little or no savings which means
that right off the bat
at least three quarters of us are broke
you might be broke number two if uh if
you have credit card debt
john you have credit card debt there's
no such thing
as good debt i don't know josh what if i
get a one percent loan and then i invest
that into the stock market and i see a
six percent return over a year and
i pay that loan off by the end of the
year and yeah there's no such thing as
good debt
oh i mean there are there are debts that
are much better than other debts
exactly sure so like you said the the
payday loan is sort of the most
insidious of all of these records
there some of them are as high as 3 500
percent
now there have been some laws been put
in place in certain states and federal
laws as well
that have limited the the um
predatory nature of some of these places
but they're still really really terrible
instead of 3 500 percent maybe it's 350
it's still awful there are exceptions
well i don't even want to say exceptions
to the rule but i mean there are
exceptions where yeah like if you're
going to buy a house
yeah it's much better to put down 20
10-year loan rather than taking out a
30-year loan with zero percent down i
mean yeah there are certainly
better debts than others and you know
we've had at this point countless number
of readers reach out to us and
tell us how they've leveraged uh debt
to to make you know to make money which
is great but that's still a risk
yeah and i would still argue that like
it's not it's still not
good debt yeah it's it's a game that
you're playing
that you are leveraging and great you
know the people who have wrote us have
won
uh i know people who have played that
game and have lost exactly exactly and
it's not a game i'm willing to play
anymore the
the debtor is always a slave to the
lender
number three you might be broke if you
have student loan debt
john you have student loan debt uh read
our lips
there's no such thing as
good debt number four you might be broke
if you have a monthly car payment
um that
is debt isn't it funny that like we're
like dude we're programmed
to have a car payment right like
we will and i'm not saying like
you know no one is um
i'm not trying to make anyone feel bad
for having payments like that's not it
at all
right but i kind of want to feel a
little i want to feel some pain
no i mean a little bit of pain yeah of
course because yeah of course
you know we'd rather see people have no
payments at all but at the end of the
day like we are programmed to budget
for a car payment for a house payment
right
and budget for debt yeah and uh
i don't know there's something that
doesn't sit well with me there you know
it becomes part of your lifestyle and
you become tethered to it and then like
i said a moment ago the debtor is always
slave to the lender you become
tethered to that lifestyle number five
you might be broke if your
income dictates your lifestyle so that's
exactly what you're
getting at there ryan it should it
should be the other way around we should
work to earn enough money to live
not live to earn enough money to buy
crap that we don't need
until he breaks free from consumerism
the hoarder
is slave to his horde
let's see here number six you might be
broke if you aren't saving
for the future we know we know you'll
start saving
tomorrow one day yeah but of course
tomorrow never comes because tomorrow
will be today tomorrow and tomorrow's
tomorrow will never
ever be today not with that attitude
ergo begin today your life
literally depends on it uh and so uh
back to what john was asking about
you know shoot i've been setting aside
20 of my income and saving it
uh you don't want to if you're in debt
no you absolutely you want to pay off
your debt you don't want to save 20
of your income here's what i'm going to
recommend here's what i i did personally
set aside 20 a month just so you can
build up the habit
you can get that momentum you're not
actually going to be saving a lot of
money
but i you can do this you can do it in a
savings account if you want i
i invested mine in index funds uh i use
a company called betterment
which we can talk about later and why i
use it and you can actually see
my exact net worth on on
our website down to the penny well down
to the penny at least as of last summer
which is the last time i updated it so
yeah you'll be able to take a look at
that
but yes you want to set aside 20 a month
not because you're you're investing in
your future in that
but you are building up that habit and i
think that's what's really important
building up that
muscle that investment muscle so you can
begin to save once you've paid off
your your debt you already have that
habit the groove
in in your daily habit will be set up so
um let's see here if you if you aren't
saving for the future uh you'll start
saving tomorrow blah blah blah alright
okay number seven
number seven you might be broke if
you're not healthy
unhealthy equals depression yes
if you are unhealthy statistics show
that you're likely to press
if you can't enjoy life no matter how
wealthy you are
then you're broke in a different way
you're broken
the richest man in the graveyard might
be might have the most lavish tombstone
but he's still dead number eight you
might be broke if your relationships are
suffering
too often we forsake the most important
people in our lives
in search of money and ephemeral
pleasures we believe that our loved ones
will always be around or that
quote they'll understand
but when you're careless with something
for long enough
it breaks i think it's important ryan
you and i
especially me i i forsook all the people
in my 20s because
they'll understand and and i'm
out being successful i'm making money
but if you're careless
with something for long enough it breaks
and that's what happened to my marriage
right
it broke and i was careless for a long
time
number nine you might be broke if you
argue over money
troubled relationships tend to end for
one of two reasons arguments over money
or arguments over sex
or both even if the relationship doesn't
end
it is difficult to grow if y'all are
constantly
bickering about finances p.s
if you're arguing over sex or the lack
thereof
then something's broken number 10
you might be broke if you're not growing
it doesn't matter how much cash you earn
if you're not growing you're dying
we feel most alive when we cultivate a
passion drudge through the drudgery
and live our lives with purpose autonomy
and mastery
number 11 last uh last one here
you might be broke if you don't
contribute as much as you'd like your
worth isn't determined by your net worth
real worth comes from contributing
beyond yourself in a meaningful way
it was martin luther king who said
life's most persistent and urgent
question is
what are you doing for others giving is
living
and it's much easier to give when you're
no longer worried about
money and then the summarize it here
being broke is okay so john being broke
is okay
being broke without a plan to break that
cycle
is not you see given the above criteria
we've all been broke at some point in
our lives everyone has been broke or
broken
true we all need money to live but you
are not the contents of your wallet
what's more important than income is how
we spend the resources we have
we personally know broke people who make
six or even seven
figures a year i can say that looking
back at
some of the people we work with ryan
knowing broke people who were
ostensibly rich but they were broke we
also know families who live on twenty
five thousand dollars a year a family of
of three here that have a link to but
who aren't broke at all
because they live within their means
they live deliberately
real wealth security and contentment
comes not from
the trinkets we amass but from how we
spin
the one life we've been given so
you can uh you can take a look at that
back back to john with with your budget
once you've once you've put a budget
together and you've set up some
boundaries and
everyone on your team you your whether
it's you have a significant other your
friends
and then of course you want to adjust
accordingly you're going to have to
change your budget as your circumstances
change and the last thing i'm going to
recommend for john is you mentioned
having a safety net i think that's great
long term you want to build up a larger
safety net but having
500 to a thousand dollars for
emergencies is great you may
need more than that but uh you'll want a
much bigger safety net once you get out
of that but you will want to get out of
debt
before you before you do that all right
one last thing john i'm going to
recommend
for you actually we're going to give you
a copy of our book essential there's an
entire chapter on
finances in that book that broke essays
in there but
there's some other stuff about finances
and financial planning and retirement
and
a bunch of other stuff that i think will
help point you in the right direction
sean if you can reach out to him and
give him a copy of that book or
if he would prefer the audio book
version of that
if you could give him an audible
download code i would appreciate that
our next question is from jimmy
jimmy in denison texas my question
is in regards to getting out of debt
but in my case we have a majority of our
debt
is medical debt we already pay
eight to nine hundred dollars every
single month
for medical insurance uh we even carry a
flex spending card
so that we would have the money to go
ahead
and pay for like the copays and
deductibles and
and uh co-insurances but it seems like
there's never enough
money to pay for the cost after the
insurance
me and my wife both work full-time we
receive
potential bonuses every single month we
have a little side venture business
to try to bring in a stream of revenue
uh to help us
um we're doing better than we ever have
before but
it's not uh it's definitely not the
savings in our that we have that we'd
like
uh we don't have the three to six months
of income
saved up and we're trying to figure out
you know how to tackle this in a way i
know that you guys talk a lot about
credit card debt and loans
student loans and i have those as well
but the medical data seems
to be what's holding uh you know a lot
of our debt
if you could get back to me you know and
at least uh maybe give me some tips that
you guys have right i love that that
word he used man he said financial
clutter
you and you and i in the past have
talked about internal clutter or
emotional clutter or spiritual clutter
but really that's what this episode is
about is financial clutter maybe we
should like
rename this episode financial financial
clutter
there are only one word episodes oh yeah
it's the law we'd be such hypocrites if
we you're not a real minimalist ryan
you use two words financial clutter
we'll make it one word oh
we make a lot of things one word we do
yeah yeah it's compound conjunctions i
call it
anyway i think that's a spot on term
here jimmy you're talking about
financial clutter so
back to your your monthly expense your
your eight to nine hundred dollars a
month
on on your medical expenses or your
insurance or both
uh get really clear on that as we as we
talked to
john about you want to know exactly how
much money is going out
because otherwise as as dave ramsey says
that
you're going to have too much month at
the end of your money
and and and that's exactly that's
exactly what will happen now
i'll just say first off congratulations
you said you're doing better than you
ever have done
that's awesome so acknowledge that let's
be grateful for that right
you're experiencing some pleasure from
doing better the pain is coming from
you don't feel like it's good enough yet
you have a little side venture
uh what i'm going to recommend is
something that so here's what i did when
i was
trying to pass some credit card debt
there was a period of time where i
delivered pizzas
now i wouldn't do that same thing now
because there's other technologies
around
whether it's a company like uber or or
lyft
or yeah i've heard garyvee talk about
this a lot
recently gary vaynerchuk he has a really
good podcast i think it's called the
gary vee
experience and uh it comes out every day
he is a real
new york hustler kind of dude he runs a
big
ad agency and while i certainly don't
agree with him on advertising and a lot
of stuff
he uh he's very inspiring with
with respect to getting out of debt or
getting people out of bad
situations and i've heard him talk a lot
he's doing something ryan called the
2017
challenge and and what he's doing is
he's encouraging people to
make twenty thousand i think what is it
twenty thousand
one hundred and seventy dollars this
year off of stuff they own in their
house
so things you already own you can sell
on ebay
and he the stat he uses is five do you
have
five to fifteen thousand dollars worth
of stuff in your house he thinks you can
flip it to make over twenty thousand
dollars
of stuff if you're willing to really
start parting with with those things so
bex and i
this month we're playing the minimalism
game we're donating a lot of stuff and
it is going to get hard
really really quick so we're just as of
this recording it's the 7th of february
we're seven days into the game now we're
playing as a family doing a little bit
different
for the people that know about the
minimalism game it's a 30-day minimalism
game you can find it at the
minimalists.com
game i won't beat you over the head with
the description but yeah
we're playing as a family instead of
like going against each other
we don't have very much stuff if you
take a tour of our home
it's like what how are you gonna get rid
of i'm impressed that you guys have made
it through day seven
and we're just getting rid of ella's
stuff it's fine we're playing the
minimalism game with our dogs yeah
yeah yeah she's nude and doesn't have
any more clothes or toys
do we feel great don't go do that
yeah and um it's really been hard
because we had to get rid of food the
last couple days
no uh you know this is only funny to you
and i i know
anyway you can find you uh a lot of
people have been playing along with us
uh on her instagram account it's just at
minimal wellness you can see photos that
she's putting up every day
anyway we're getting rid of stuff and
i'm realizing that like
ebay became one of my best friends when
i was getting out of debt ebay
craigslist selling stuff that was over
20 bucks i'm like i can i can make money
off of this and garyvee's like man you
can go to the dollar store and buy
he had a story of one guy who bought i
think it was like eight thousand dollars
worth of stuff from this dollar store
just and and was able to sell them for
five bucks a pop
uh because he had the ebay app right on
his phone and was like oh my goodness do
you have
all of these these yeah i can buy this
thing for a dollar and sell it for five
and while i don't want you to go into
debt to do something like that
that would be stupid but if the point
being is
you have things that you can sell right
now online that you're no longer getting
value from
to start get your way out of debt and
then you can also supplement your income
temporarily feel that temporary pain
jimmy with uber or lyft or delivering
pizzas or something else
that is going to help you get out of
debt because once you get out of debt
that freedom is going to taste
way better than than the the passive
sort of extra hour or so that you had
and that's the nice thing about
any of the and we're not sponsored by
uber or lyft or any other company like
that but the nice thing is you can
maybe you're not wait a minute
um yeah and so the nice thing is you can
turn that on for an hour or two hours or
whatever and i've talked to a bunch of
different uber drivers
and lyft drivers who were like yeah i i
do this for an hour two hours or 10
hours on my day off
and and i get to dictate my own schedule
i think that's great that'll help you
pay off your debt
and and if you do that enough you you'll
really start to develop that plan so
ryan mentioned with with john earlier
you got to have that budget you got to
have
a plan so get that need want like list
together
and then or the other plan could be dave
ramsey's baby steps right
which he he talks about in in his book
yeah it sounded to me like when he was
talking about the medical debt that
sounded like probably the
largest debt that he has right now yes
and
dave ramsey would tell you to start with
the sm either the smallest debt or like
the biggest interest
loan i'm saying start with your smallest
debt it's the smallest
snowball so regardless of what the
interest rate is on your debts
unless there's something that's going to
send you into bankruptcy then you'll
want to tackle that first but otherwise
uh yeah you start with the smallest debt
first is that snowball so if you have
like
16 different things right yeah so
starting with the largest debt like
that's going to be
the most difficult thing is right yeah
you still have to pay your minimums on
it obviously
whatever your minimums might be but then
everything every extra dollar you have
you throw your smallest debt uh sean we
bought a case of dave ramsey's book a
total money makeover
so if we have a copy of that if not he
can have my personal copy if you'd send
it to him
i'd appreciate that dave also has
something else ryan that
that i like i wish i would have had
because i used to use that envelope
system that he recommends
total money makeover but now he has an
app
that's a free app on your phone it's
called everything these days and he
spent a couple million dollars putting
this app together and it's a free app
and it's
awesome it does a great job it's called
every dollar we'll put a link to that
in in the show notes as well so jimmy
like don't yeah i was just gonna
say jimmy like don't stress yourself out
about making an extra 20 grand this year
i mean if you can
great uh but you know just to that point
start with start with 100 bucks a week
so 20 grand a year is about 400 bucks a
week that's that's like twenty thousand
eight hundred dollars what that would be
uh if you can start with a hundred
dollars a week that's an extra you know
fifty two hundred dollars in a year
i'm certain that that would help you so
if twenty thousand dollars is like way
too big of a number for you to
start thinking like these guys are crazy
i don't have twenty thousand dollars
worth of stuff in my house to sell
you may or may not uh but yes then start
with a smaller
number but you know doing uber i know
you can make extra hundred bucks a week
doing uber
we're not telling yeah we're not telling
you to like you know
drive yourself crazy and work 100 hour
weeks for the rest of your life but
sometimes
when when we find ourselves in
situations like this we do have to
uh deprive ourselves of some time
uh so we can you know uh temporarily do
that so we can get ourselves out of a
hole
so yeah maybe it's not 20 grand maybe
that's not the number but
uh maybe it's 5 000 bucks maybe it's
just 100 bucks a week but just start
there
with 50 bucks a week we'll get inspired
and i think you'll find out really
quickly
if you go look at the 2017 challenge
that garyvee has out there look at all
the people on instagram who are like
i had no idea i had 20 000 worth of
stuff in my house and sold it all in
three weeks
and all of a sudden i was able to pay
off my debt or i was able to start my
business or my side venture or
i was able to do something what is your
outcome jimmy you got to ask you got to
know what that question is it sounds to
me like your outcome is becoming
debt-free becoming
financially free as well and if you know
that outcome
you need to be able to associate enough
pleasure with that and enough pain with
the state you're being in right now
that you are willing to work some crazy
hours temporarily
not in perpetuity like ryan said you
don't want to you don't want to do it
forever
that would be misery that'd be despair
but if you can see the light at the end
of the tunnel
that's what your outcome is then be
willing to sacrifice temporarily
not long-term sacrifice but temporary
sacrifice so you can get to
to where you want to be in the future
anything else before we move on to
another question yeah i think once you
get to that place the most important
piece of advice is don't get back into
debt
um yes yeah that's that is key i think
too often we get all that
ah just be one credit card i'll just
have one
one credit card and then it's like you
know what
that jet ski is looking really nice
summer's right around you know i could
probably pay it off by end of the year
right are you giving me a jet ski for
christmas
[Laughter]
uh yeah yeah we're gonna put it on my
credit card
was that from the south park episode i
put it on my
credit card the impression of the the
average american was eyes wide open
with uh i'm going to put it on my credit
card yeah that's sad
that's the rest of the world's
impression on us but it's true
all right our next question is from
nathan who's also in texas he is in
college station texas
i know you guys went through a corporate
phase and around 27 28 is when you
really start this minimalist movement
but as far as your advice to
me i'm actually um engaged to
one of my dreams and we're getting
married in july
so we are currently about to
spring into uh the job market
um get work stuff like that done get
married
and this is something really interesting
that i'm really interested in
and i have yet to talk to her about it
uh we'll talk to you soon but what is
your advice to
us as we go into um
you know the real world beyond college
um
as far as like how to handle the
transition from financials you know
because i have debt coming out of
college and
how to look at you know things in terms
of where we can live
why should we live there things like
that so
i know it's a very general question but
financially
what would look like a minimalist
approach coming out of college
first off thanks for your honesty uh
nathan uh
first off congratulations uh you're
getting married really soon
and and um i want to say thank you for
your honesty because
you said you're yet to talk to your
fiance about the money stuff
and to me that's a huge red flag because
that's what most of us forget to do
before we get into some sort of
relationship we don't talk about money
why because it's a sensitive subject
yeah i think that's important too man
cause when you
marry this girl and when she marries you
her debt is your debt
yeah and your dad has heard that and
there are you know some people out there
who are married and they keep their
debts separate
which is fine uh but they've talked that
out beforehand or maybe they haven't and
it's caused contention but either way
um when you well legally her debt is
your debt
yes yeah i mean so whether how you view
it or not that is the law and her income
is your income your income is her income
and
i find the best way to treat it is to
treat it that way if you're going to be
if you're going to be married and you
want to be in a happy marriage
you have to be an open book and quite
literally here
with respect to the finances you need to
be an open book so the first thing you
need to do
is sit down have a conversation with her
about finances and it's not going to be
just
one one conversation right it's going to
be
multiple conversations and monthly
budget meetings and hopefully
you have the same ideas about debt
you're not going to get into debt
uh you're you so so here's here's some i
guess advice i would give my 22
23 year old self i'm not sure how old
you are nathan but my guess you're
you're right around there and you're
asking all the right questions at all
the right times questions like that when
i was that age yeah you're setting
yourself
up for success so questions i was asking
at 22 is how much
how much debt payments can i afford
right
seriously yeah yeah how much can i
afford and and
that just really meant like can i make
more money so i can afford more
debt how many debt payments can i afford
to bring into my life
and so so here's here's the advice i
would give to my younger self and
hopefully some of this
will help with you and your fiance
nathan what are your values what are her
values
and the reason that question is is so
important it's going to help you
identify
where are you going and where are you
going there together and can you get
there together financially right
and then what's important to you what
makes you happy what makes her happy
what makes her angry what makes her so
pissed that she wants to do something
about it what makes you so pissed that
you want to do something about it
those that will help you identify like
after college what's the direction i'm
going to take right
am i just going to have a job working
for someone so like ryan i can make
those debt
payments or am i going to have a career
now
here's what i'll actually say i think a
career is one of the most dangerous
things you can have
and the reason i say that and it's not
just
semantics here i delineate between
a job a career and a mission
and i think it's okay to have a job we
all have to pay the bills
and sometimes our mission in life is
different from what we do to earn a
paycheck
sometimes we we have this thing called a
career that means
quite often we'll sacrifice our values
to make you know we'll put money first
basically
and we'll sacrifice and forsake the
things that are actually most important
i had a really great career at one point
ryan
but it didn't align with my values the
fact it covered up my values to the
point where i didn't know
the direction i needed to go in to to be
passionate to be content to live more
meaningfully
and so the third thing you can have is a
mission what is your mission in life
and and i think figuring out what makes
you happy or what makes you angry
can help you maybe identify that mission
doesn't mean you have to do that to earn
a paycheck but if you can
now's a good time to try that out
especially if you have no debt
so the next thing i'd say is make sure
you don't get into debt
if you don't have any debt right now
don't get into debt if you do have debt
pay it off including those student loans
work really really really
hard to pay off that that that uh
student loan debt
and the last thing i would ask you and
and your fiance
is who's the person you want to become
who do you want to be where do you see
your
25 year old self at this point what is
that person doing in an ideal
world do they have a lot of debt do they
have a bunch of student loans are they
working a career that they don't love
i doubt it i really doubt that's the
direction you want to go in and so
don't go in that direction who's the
person that you want to become
and then shape your life around that of
course that's not going to be
easy it's going to be simple though if
you make
some some simple choices with your life
and
the last thing ryan we could probably
talk about from from me is
you want it now is the perfect time to
start planning
for retirement for them they're just
getting out of college
once you pay off that debt and that you
have or even now
if you're going to put at least 20 bucks
a month away so you build up that muscle
as we talked to john about earlier you
want to start planning
for the long term you want to plan for
your future and so there's an essay i'm
going to recommend and i'll read a
little bit about it and hopefully ryan
and i can riff on it
a bit it's on our website it's from
last year it's called retirement
planning how to plan for a successful
retirement and in here you'll see
screenshots of my exact
finances and ryan followed a very
similar plan as well
an essay goes like this youth is wasted
on the young
often money is too back in my corporate
days when i manage scores of retail
stores and hundreds of employees
i stress the importance of planning for
retirement as well as saving for future
goals
with every person i hired before that or
before the start of their very first
shift i would sit down with each new
team member
and show them how to save for retirement
without stress worry
complexity or pain within a few minutes
i could literally see the difference in
their
physiological and their physiology as
trepidation drained from their facial
features
and after we spent 30 minutes examining
their options
confidence began to take over once they
realized planning for retirement
is much simpler than they thought this
was something ryan that that was really
interesting to me i remember
most people who worked for us or with us
who were in their 20s didn't even think
about their 401k
or whatever because it was so
overwhelming
i'm not even going to want to think
about that i'm just going to put it off
because i don't want to have to deal
with that
right yeah and and what i found is if
you just take 30 minutes to
at least think about it and automate
some stuff then
you're going to change your future
selves life
and you're going to feel good about that
now so what seth godin talked about
making decisions to feel good now you
make that decision to start investing in
your future self
you're going to feel great and i'm not
going to read this whole this whole
essay because
it's pretty long but i'll just go
through the
there are some retirement myths that i
was able to debunk
in in this essay so uh before i get
let's see myth number one i'm too old to
save for retirement well that obviously
doesn't apply to nathan right
he's he's young right we'll get to that
in a second though uh
myth number two is i'm too young to say
for for retirement
so i spent a whole paragraph debunking
the the
i'm too old to say for retirement
actually i i like i like i'll read this
real quick
um i frequently hired employees who are
older than i was
often in their 40s and 50s with no
retirement savings plan so if that's you
and you're listening to this
then listen up fear had long ago set in
and they figured it was
too late they were stuck they had missed
their opportunity
it's not true while it's true that
you're better off starting at age 25
or nathan at age 22 or wherever you're
at it's better to start at age 25 than
age 50. it's also true that you're
better off starting at age 50
than say age 70. then again 70 is a
better start than 90 isn't it
the past is the past we must stop
peering at the rear view
and instead look ahead toward the
horizon as long as you're still
breathing
it's never too late to start it's never
too early either
so that's myth number two i'm too young
to save for retirement retirement
too young then by the way that's so so
many people
who work for me would say like ah i'll
worry about that when i'm older
i'll worry about that when i'm 30. yeah
i saw my uh
uh i'll say a relative i don't want to
like say what relative my friend slash
relative slash
reader listener yes uh
long story short they waited till they
were like 38 39
like really start saving for retirement
and i just remember the payment it was
like
five or six hundred bucks a month they
had to save in order to have enough
retirement by
you know 60 or 65. yeah but dude that's
a lot of money yeah
to save every single month and like you
said they had to save it yeah it wasn't
a choice right and i remember
uh they were whatever the number was by
the time i got to 65 i'm
you know i'm certain that someone could
save 20 bucks a month right uh yeah and
and still um have a decent savings uh
but regardless what i'm saying is is
that if they were started at 22
that payment would have been much much
much less absolutely
in fact here's here's a stat for you so
here's what i said too young are you
insane
if you're younger than 30 you have it
made
young people no matter your tax bracket
have a significant
opportunity to become truly wealthy
thanks
thanks to the power of compound interest
so listen to this this hopefully nathan
this stat blows your mind and sticks
with you and
convinces you to start investing in your
future right now so
someone who invests 25 000 by age
25 with a 12 rate of return
will have more than 2 million dollars
by age 65 even even if he or she doesn't
add another dollar after age 25. yeah
that's crazy
25 thousand dollars you have more than
two million dollars
even if you don't uh uh invest another
dollar conversely if that same person
waits
like your friend relative relative enemy
did um
uh if that person waits until age
30 he or she will have to contribute
more than three times
as much to achieve the same outcome
what's the lesson here compound interest
is the best way to grow your money over
the long haul
so start while you're young to visually
illustrate the difference between age 25
and 30 there's a chart in
in the essay there at the minimalist.com
retirement
here's myth number three i heard this
one all the time
i don't make enough money to save for
retirement
not with that attitude actually there is
no reason you shouldn't retire a
millionaire and i when i first wrote
this people got mad
like when i when i first said that and
then
so i just back it up with some numbers
here right
these aren't the numbers i'm not the
first person to say this obviously
there are plenty of financial investors
so that's right virtually
everyone even minimum wage earners has
the
opportunity to be a millionaire when
they retire
it sounds to be good too good to be true
but the math proves otherwise
and here's the math for you a 20 we're
filing us back under the math
section of podcasts right sean uh a 25
year old
who is there like is there an actual
math section on itunes do you think
i'm sure there are like a math and
science section maybe can you imagine
listening to a math podcast
some people can so you actually really
like math maybe you'd enjoy a math
podcast
uh maybe you'll enjoy this one then ryan
a 25 year old who sets aside only 23
dollars per week
23 dollars per week will retire with
more than a million dollars
wow if the money is invested properly
and i give a 12
rate of return there okay so maybe how
do they do that do they buy gold
well if i had a million dollars first
thing i'm gonna do is buy a bunch of
gold
gold chains gold watches yeah man gold
figaro's
yes 1998 called
um anyway uh okay so maybe you're not 25
anymore me either that's right us older
folks simply need to adjust accordingly
and then i use something called
betterment and there's a better i have a
link here to a betterment investment and
retirement calculator to help you
understand exactly how much money you
need to save based on
your age and financial objectives let's
see here
so you can find that calculator in the
essay as well myth number four
but inflation will hurt my retirement
nest egg
uh-huh this is the only true this is the
only myth that is partially true however
the truth here is irrelevant while it is
true that a hundred dollars ten years
from now will probably possess
less buying power than a hundred dollars
today
the flip side of that coin is also true
and considerably more important
your hundred dollars ten years from now
will be worth
infinitely more than your friends zero
dollars that he invested
in fact solid investments are the only
way to
outpace inflation it is better invest
your hundred dollars than to keep in the
keep it in the bank or uh under your
mattress
right so yes you want to invest but even
just putting in a savings account is
better than doing nothing at all
yeah i mean at least you get like a one
percent return on that yeah and even if
you got a zero percent
return it's better than not saving it at
all yeah and so you you want to do
something
with your money for sure myth number
five i'd rather spend my money on
something else
when intentions are good this excuse
occasionally sounds like the most
compelling reason to avoid saving for
the future
true we sometimes cling selfishly to
money using our income to purchase
superfluous trinkets of
ostensible success new cars shiny
gadgets accoutrements of consumerism
but frequently we want to use our money
to contribute beyond ourselves
to charities and nonprofits and loved
ones in need
contributing to others is certainly
admirable and i believe that giving is
living
so i want you to contribute generously
but i found the best way to keep
to to help others is to help yourself
first
the best way to give generously is what
to have
more to give to other people investing
yourself first
helps you flex your giving muscle
there's a reason airlines tell you to
secure your own oxygen mask before
helping others
if it's easier to breathe it's easier
for you to help people in need
and i think that's important i want you
to be able to give i want everybody to
give generously
ryan and i have been fortunate enough
these last few years to be able to give
very generously because we got our
houses in order
first and i think that's important we've
done everything from from
fund high schools to build elementary
schools to build orphanages
to contribute to the the victims of of
the orlando
shooting thousands of dollars and and uh
we've been able to do that because we
got our houses in order first and i
think that's really important
myth number six the stock market isn't
safe
translation you don't understand
the stock market that's okay i don't
completely understand the stock market
either
not intimately anyway i'm not a
financial advisor nor do i play one on
the internet
the only people who must have an
advanced understanding of stock markets
intricacies
are stock brokers day traders and fund
managers
rather rather than allocating several
hours a day
to learn the nuances of mutual funds
index funds and individual stocks
i choose to use an investing service
that takes the guesswork out of it
it's true that any investment introduces
risk into the equation but long-term
investing in the stock market has proven
to be the best way to grow your
retirement savings
over the last 25 years including and
this is an important part here
including 2008 steep decline and
subsequent great recession
the market has averaged a rate of return
of nearly 11
given when you account for 1928's great
depression the stock market has averaged
9 growth over the past 100 years and i
have a source here
so investing in in the market is the
most stable good growth investment one
can make in the long term especially
when using
online tools that help you outperform
the market
many of which are discussed in this
essay so
i discuss i use something called
betterment there's also a company called
wealthfront and if you're overseas later
on
in the added value portion i'm going to
talk about some other companies if
you're overseas that might help you out
with your overseas investing because the
company i use
is is not available overseas and sean is
salivating right now because we get so
many questions
about this anyway uh last myth i have
here ryan is myth number seven
i don't have enough time or knowledge to
manage my retirement savings
it's true that i will likely never have
as much financial wisdom as the experts
but that's precisely why we must seek
out tools developed by trusted
reputable experts although i'm usually a
do-it-yourself kind of guy
i don't diy my investment strategy
rather i did the research and found an
online investment and found online
investment tools
that allow me to control my money
without being overly controlling
i don't want to constantly scrutinize my
investments in fact i'm going to
encourage most people when you start
setting aside money the market's going
to go down you're going to put money in
and at some point it's going to go down
you're going to freak out stop looking
at your investments put them there
look at it once a year if you have to
but other than that
leave it alone drive yourself crazy
looking every day yeah and and
those one day you'd be like oh my god i
just made 700 bucks and the next day
you're gonna be like oh my god i just
lost a thousand bucks i mean you're
gonna put yourself on a roller coaster
and and there's science behind this ryan
that proves that
the pain always feels worse than the
pleasure of it so you can say oh
oh my god i made a thousand dollars that
feels cool all right that was neat
and you move on but then you're like oh
my god i lost a thousand dollars this
week
i should pull my money out but i don't
know what to do
and you the pain is much more acute and
so uh keep that in mind so
in the essay i go through the tools i
use you can find
literally screenshots of all my
investment accounts i invest into five
different buckets
i'm sorry four different buckets uh
there's a safety net so i keep my
my emergency fund it's called a safety
net of a year's worth
of pay uh in in my account it took me a
long time to build that safety net
but that's where i keep it and it grows
a little bit
but it's a more conservative mix of
stocks and
index funds and then and then i
have a traditional ira which is
basically just
roll over from when we were in the
corporate world i rolled our old for
my old 401 k into the traditional ira
and then i have two other two other
funds i have a build wealth fund which
is like
just my regular investments and then i
have a
house fund as well because as i
mentioned on the last episode episode 58
home
if i want to buy a home one day i want
to be able to put 50 down so i
this is where i save that money so you
can see exactly how much money i've got
in there
and and why i use what i use
uh in terms of planning for my
retirement but for nathan
ryan is there any anything else besides
hey you should really need to start
getting on the same page with your
fiance
make sure you don't get into debt plan
for your retirement what else
should should he do what would you tell
your 22
23 year old self if you're in his
position just getting out of
texas a m college he's finishing up he's
getting married
what advice yeah if i had to talk to my
22 year old self i would tell myself two
things
uh first and foremost yes like stay out
of debt at all costs
um yeah working a debt payment into
your monthly budget is not the best
advice now
there's somebody out there who's like
well i gotta have a car to get to my job
you know so i can pay my bills including
that car payment sure
well then get the cheapest car possible
that doesn't mean you gotta go get a
200 a month car payment you can go find
a car for three or four thousand bucks
yeah
uh have it paid off in a year or two
years or whatever it may be so if you're
going to get into the debt
uh which again i advise
strongly not to do get in as little debt
as possible
uh the other thing is and man this is
like such simple advice
but you know simple ain't easy amen
spend
less money than what you make yes
i really wish i could have told my 22
year old self that because there is
something about
being you know 22 and half and starting
to have the freedom of credit cards and
being able to get into debt
and i would just you know basically lie
to myself
and say oh well one day you're gonna
make more money you'll be able to pay
all this off
and you know what i did one day i did
like when i was you know 24
23 that's when i started slanging cell
phones and making good money but
i still had that attitude of if i make
it i have to spend it
yeah and spending more money than what i
had essentially so
uh that people always ask me now like
you know what is
uh you know what's you know how do you
do your budget now so forth and so on
and it's like i do have a budget
but regardless i always make sure to
spend less than what i make
yeah and i just i wish i could have like
really just drilled that into my
my younger 20 year old self was spend
less money than what i make and stay out
of debt at all costs
i work really hard so i pay myself my
future self
and at the beginning of each month so i
i instantly put it into my retirement
account i
i try to save 50 of what i earn i'm not
recommending that for everyone else
i'm saying for what i make if i if i can
save 50
i feel outstanding about that but then
there's a minimum that i try to save as
well is 15
right so i pay myself at least 15
whatever i make
instantly goes in into my betterment
account
every month and if i can i feel really
good about
all right how much money can i put in
there this month all right i'm going to
do that
how much money can and and still live
the lifestyle i live because i'm debt
free now and so
i don't have to worry about every single
penny that i'm spending but i'm paying
my future self
first i invest in my future first and
then i give myself permission to spend
other money
if if i need it all right well of course
we would love to hear what you all have
to say
so if you have a comment about finances
money
debt etc or if you have any any tips any
advice for our callers today then leave
us a voicemail 406-219-7839
we will air our favorite comments and
tips on the next episode and here is a
tip for you
write down your message before you call
it will help you articulate your point
and increase your chances of being on
the show
did we give nathan a book or something
are we gonna
we probably should yeah yeah let's give
him something let's send him well i
asked him about values right
and so ryan and i wrote a a book called
minimalism live a meaningful life it's
the first book that that you and i wrote
and it's about the five higher order
values that
we uncovered and i think that's uh uh
it's gonna help him and his
his partner his soon-to-be wife uh it's
gonna help them
identify what their values are and so
i'd love to send you a copy of that sean
if you could reach out to nathan good
call ryan
uh if you could reach out to to nathan
uh have him read that book or listen to
the book if you have an audible download
code another book i'm gonna recommend uh
no
i'm thinking of it our friend rob bell
and his wife kristen bell
they wrote a book called the zim zom of
love which is like i think an old hebrew
word or something
zimzam and and it's about sort of the
yang and yang of love i
i can't do it justice but uh they wrote
this book together
and um i don't have a cop an extra copy
of it but sean if you could
just buy one um yeah buy one for him and
send it over to him
uh for and i think him and his his
future wife
will find a lot of value in the zim zom
of love as well as our our book
minimalism
all right let's move on to our hashtag
ask the minimalists lightning round
where we answer
questions from social media we are on
twitter and instagram at the minimalist
and facebook.com slash the minimalist
during this lightning round this is
where ryan and i do our best to answer
each question with just a short
shareable
less than 140 character response we also
put the text
to these minimal maxims in the sean
notes
so that you can copy and share our pithy
answers on social media if you'd like
all right our first question is from
carl when
is the right time to pay debt off slowly
hint i think they're giving us an answer
here
hint kids in medicine well i have just a
really long answer i couldn't come up
with a short answer for this one ryan so
here's my long answer
there's no such thing as good debt
that's pretty good man what about you
ryan
i would say there's no such thing as
good debt
no but seriously like you know hints
kids in medicine
yes like if you have okay i'm just gonna
throw a scenario out here
i'm sure someone is is like facing this
where uh
okay they have a 500 a month medical
bill
they need to pay for insulin for their
kid to live
yeah they also have uh you know this
debt that's looming over them
and at the end of the month they have to
choose whether or not they're going to
spend 500
towards that debt or on their kids
insulin of course they're going to
choose the insulin but the problem
with this scenario is that this person
that i'm talking about is waiting until
the end of the month
to plan for that yes so that's that is
the the biggest issue
is you know going back to find a way
that you can make an extra 50 bucks a
week
and there's plenty of ways to do that
uber
lyft delivering pizzas go donate plasma
i like i
seriously i mean i'm not like saying
that everyone should like go out and
donate
plasma there are you know people who
believes
would uh i don't know why i do know why
being raised as a jehovah's witness but
i know some people's beliefs are going
to like automatically
cross that out in cert good idea to make
50 bucks there
yeah good here's the thing my guess is
carl doesn't have a written budget
i i i'd be willing to bet a thousand
dollars that he doesn't have a written
budget that he sticks to
um and that's not a dis to carl the
truth is that
99 of the country doesn't have a written
budget a written budget and if they do
they don't stick to it and that that's
the more important you can have a
written budget but if you don't
if it's just written and that's it it's
nothing it's worthless
you wasted your time on it so what's the
best time to pay off debt slowly
there there is no no best time to pay
off debt slowly
you want to pay off debt if you can't
afford to pay it off right now then you
can't afford to pay it off right now
but you want to pay it off as quickly as
you can because there's no such thing
as a good debt amen next question is
from rachel
hey lads she must be from new jersey
any chance you could turn my minimal
finances into maximum ones
all right uh let's see my my maxim here
is
the best way to give yourself a pay
raise is to spend less money remember
what our employees
hated when we said that to them
i need a raise why don't you spend less
money hey man
how about how about you don't have a
hummer remember that we had like
employees with hummers
we had we had a retail store where three
employees
three front line employees owned hummers
humvees hummer two or whatever
because they could afford the payment
right they couldn't afford the car there
was three hummers and a corvette parked
out
in front in front of the store one time
and i was uh
uh yeah it was unbelievable and so yes
the best way to give yourself a pay
raise
is truly to spend less money here is my
answer with the correctly placed
modifier money
can solve only so many problems
that's true so what i'm saying to you
rachel is that
if josh and i have magic wand and for
anyone else out there and we could just
wave a one and give you millions of
dollars
sure like if you're in a place right now
where you're on the street
and you have you know no food and your
kids are starving like there is a
certain point
money will certainly add a level of uh
i want to say happiness but i think it
goes beyond happiness it's
uh certain nourishment yeah certainty
yeah
and uh that will go only so far yeah you
don't need a million dollars to to be
to be happy a million dollars won't
change most people's lives for the
better it will change it for the worse
a million dollars wouldn't change my
life for the better or worse i'm not a
millionaire
but um i can tell you that a million
bucks
would make certain things easier for me
but it's not going to change my habits
i was married to uh
a gal whose dad was president of a bank
right
and there were i believe he told me six
people
in his tenure as bank president that won
the lottery
five of the six were bankrupt and the
only person that
actually had money uh
and the reason why they still had money
is when they won the lottery they did
nothing different with their lives
yeah they literally put in the bank and
they continued
life as normal and didn't go and do
crazy stuff i actually met one of the
guys believe it or not
uh who was one of the six who who won
the lottery
and he long story short
um i got invited to play poker at his
place
it was a trailer no electricity and the
the toilet had been replaced with a five
gallon bucket so like you could pee in
the you could pee in the five gallon
bucket
yeah like this is a true story man and
um i just asked him about like what he
did with the money
and he loved telling the stories about
what he did with the money but there we
were like no electricity
playing like texas hold'em oh no like
with a you know five dollar buy-in
yeah because it doesn't change your
habits in fact it accentuates them and
so
the nice thing is now if someone were to
hand me a million dollars
i would i already have the good habits
in place and i have to make sure i
continue
living with those good habits but it
would allow me to contribute more to the
world around me
and it would allow me to save more for
the future but my lifestyle would not
change at all
right i'm not going to go buy more
clothes or you know i'd build more
schools like if if i'd won the lottery
tomorrow like i would
yeah i'd be i'd be you know uh even more
of a philanthropist i guess i wouldn't
guess i wouldn't really consider myself
that right now but
i would i mean i mean two large examples
you do you do a lot of good
with with your money and and it's great
and it's not like tooting your own horn
but what's nice is if we can inspire
other people to
to contribute you feel great from doing
it it is it's not a completely
altruistic act
it's there's something in there that
makes you feel
really darn good that's why i've said
twice this episode giving is living
you feel most alive when you're able to
contribute to the world around you yeah
all right our next question is from luke
how can i budget in a house full of
non-minimalists
all right so this will echo something i
said earlier but in a much more
pithy answer much pithier answer you're
so pithy
all right let's see uh luke agree on
outcomes before
agreeing on action that's good man that
is pithy
thank you you know i've been listening
to this podcast the whole time and i
don't remember
remember you saying that well i was
talking about what is your outcome
oh i asked nathan earlier well what's
your outcome so agree on your outcome
before you agree on taking
quite often i think the problem is
around like i'm going to do this we're
going to do this we're going to save
we're going to do
that what's your outcome because you
might start running in one direction
you really you're running in the wrong
direction you know where you're running
what you're running towards yeah what
direction
uh here's my pithy response you don't
have to be
a minimalist to follow a budget
yeah amen next question is from alyssa
how do you afford to pay for a wedding
well my short answer is if you have to
go into debt
you can't afford it now i think that
applies to weddings but i think that
applies
to everything whether it's a car a house
whatever if you have to go into debt
you can't afford it well i mean i mean
just to like
because i don't want to sound like an
[ __ ] like
well well if you can't afford a wedding
then you're not mature enough to get
married like that's gonna say that
i don't know i know i know maybe you're
saying you can't afford a wedding
projecting i'm projecting if you want a
300 000 wedding
but you don't have three hundred
thousand dollars then you can't afford a
three hundred thousand dollar wedding no
it's not you still have a wedding that
that doesn't cost anyone
well here here's my short answer a
wedding doesn't need to cost an arm and
a leg
to make it a meaningful experience yeah
and again and i guess if i was just
going to expound
on on any adv on advice for weddings
you do not want to start your wedding
you don't want to start your marriage
off
with you know a 10 or 20 thousand dollar
debt do you know how many people i know
and this is unfortunate like and i'm not
saying that this is gonna happen to luke
by any
no i'm sorry not luke but alyssa i'm not
gonna say this is happening to alyssa by
any stretch
but you know how many people i know are
divorced and they still have wedding
debt
like it's it is more than more than i'd
than i uh care to admit
i had student loan debt i don't have a
college degree i had student loan debt
many years after taking some college
classes and i'll just put it off and
same thing yeah and
what does that do to the relationship
it's strange strange yeah like
like you're you're literally starting
off the marriage with
with stress from an expensive wedding
i mean that is tension you're creating
unneeded tension yeah it's uh
there's gonna be people out there who
still do it josh yeah and i wish them
all the best of luck
yes but you're gonna need more than luck
i wish them way more than luck yeah
all right let's move on to our last
question i know josh has got a long
answer for this one uh-huh
chris how do you guys feel about
student debt all right here's how i feel
there is no such thing as good
debt how about you ryan that's good man
i would say
there's no such thing as good debt
all right his ears are blown by now and
everyone else who's listening to this
no but you know there's no such let's
just leave it there there's no such
thing as good day yeah
and you know what i'll say is is that at
our
i think it was our miami event
uh when we were uh touring with the
documentary
but someone asked this question and of
course we gave you know
same answers um but there was a gal who
like she stood up i don't even know you
remember there's not but she stood up
and she spoke and she was like
if you want to know she's like i'm a
doctor i'm a physician yeah and i got
through school with
zero debt if you want to know how i did
it feel free to talk to me after
after this and i will tell you how i was
able to go to school
yeah debt-free it wasn't easy like she
prefaced it
it was really difficult it was really
really difficult but she was able to put
herself through
uh school to become a doctor eight years
of school you know what's more difficult
and having no debt at the end of it
having hundreds of thousands of dollars
worth of debt afterward
and sulking in that debt being trapped
to that debt
that is more difficult so yeah if if
you're going to go through college and
you can't afford to pay for it which i
certainly couldn't have at the time
you know you you have the opportunity
to follow someone else's recipe there is
someone else out there
who is a doctor who is an attorney who
is a
uh i don't know who has their underwater
dog walking degree
whatever it may be there's a person who
has done that
who had a recipe and you can follow
their recipe and get the same result
to get out of college completely
debt-free it's going to require more
work
more effort you might have to work
another job you have to apply for grants
and scholarships there are things you
have to do
but hopefully you can avoid that debt
because there's no such thing as good
debt
all right let's move on to our added
value portion of the show this is where
we each recommend something that has
added
value to our lives recently ryan has
anything
added value to your life recently yes
this is a local recommendation for
the skiers and snowboarders in missoula
so i know that there are people who
definitely listen to our podcast who are
from
missoula um and i know there's a certain
percentage of them who like winter
sports like i do
and there's probably a certain
percentage of those people who have been
told to never go to snowbowl
because of how difficult it is and uh
the terrain there is you know
definitely not for beginners i will say
that yes it is a challenging course but
snowball is one of my most favorite like
when they have good snow
it's probably my favorite place to go
snowboarding uh and there are
well around here within like an hour and
a half drive radius
and there are at least one two three
there are at least five
different places i can think of and
snowball is by far
number one when they have tons of snow
like just like any other place when they
don't have snow it's not as good
um but yeah if you're one of those
people who you're like oh i've avoided
snowball because i've heard of how rough
it is and how hard it is just go
you're gonna love it yeah especially
like well i'm trying to think this is
the seventh and it just got it just
that's not the closest one to here is it
snowball yeah is it okay so bex takes uh
ella there occasionally i think they
have the kids yeah actually if i had a
kid that's where i would probably teach
them because it is such a hard course to
do but if you can learn how to
ski on that hill yeah then you got a
pretty good
future and it's relatively inexpensive
too oh yeah it's super cheap
yeah so it's like yeah like 40 bucks for
a lift ticket 45 bucks which is
um actually kids are free there for
around here
45 bucks is actually kind of expensive
you can go other places for like 30 35
bucks
i just remember that that ella gets in
for free that's why i thought it was so
cheap aspen or something yeah yeah
i think yeah under like seven years old
they get free i think
i think i don't know yeah yeah but yeah
go check it out if you've been timid
because
of the rumors you've heard like go check
it out for yourself and then decide
all right well uh we've had a bunch of
questions you know because i
often recommend betterment is who i use
there's also another company called
wealthfront that i know some people use
to get value in
um you can see my betterment account in
that retirement essay that i mentioned
earlier
but a lot of people are like but i'm not
in the united states i'm in canada
i'm in the uk or australia or somewhere
in europe
and so i pulled up these three articles
and we'll put links to these in the show
notes
do you know what quora is ryan the the
yeah it's like a
a website where you can just ask
questions and then the best answers get
voted up basically so these
these are not uh recommendations i'm
necessarily making
but for people who are overseas or in
canada
here are some recommendations so this
one is it says are there any european
alternatives to investment platforms
like betterment wealthfront etc
and the number one answer on this says
there are several
european alternatives for instance
united kingdom has something called
nutmeg and i saw a bunch of people
recommend nutmeg
so we'll just put a link to this rashaan
don't put a link to each one of these
individual things we'll put a link to
this article here
wealth wealth horizon fiverr
a day which sounds pretty interesting
like say 75 bucks a day i don't know
anything about it
scalable money farm money on toast
and wealthify uh germany there's some
recommendations here
france there's uh two or three
recommendations
austria there's a recommendation for a
place called scalable
switzerland there's a couple
recommendations spain belgium
and a couple other places as well and
there's also a
a nice little graphic here that shows
the the history of many of these places
some of them like nutmeg have been
around for a long time
like since 2011 which is a lot in the
robo investment world
so that's that's uk and europe in terms
of
australia it looks like there was a
couple here
stock spot was sort of the main
robo advisor for australia there are
some other ones in
this article hedgeable was one
as well so again we'll put a link to
that quiet growth
is is another one that someone
recommended so
some there are definitely some options
out there if you're australian and then
if you're canadian there are a bunch of
a bunch of recommendations here a
separate article here
wealth bar wealth simple share owner
nest wealth smart money investments
so there are a bunch there again we'll
put a link to all of that and what else
is that actually added value to my life
recently
um kevin rose has something called the
journal if you just go to
the journal dot email i think it is or
maybe it's just let me look it up real
quick i don't want to be wrong
it's either journal.email or
thejournal.email
journal.email
nope that's not it so it's gotta be the
journal.email
kevin rose is a guy who found a dig and
some other companies he's
he sends out just a monthly newsletter
of things that have added value to his
life recently
awesome so whether it's a movie or
product something that he really likes
there aren't any advertisements in there
he just wrote about this
and it's just something he's really
enjoyed over the last month and he'll
send it out to maybe it's an album maybe
it's a movie
maybe maybe it's a book maybe it's a
product he'll send it out
things that he he's really found value
in so i like that and then i've been
listening uh this weekend
our our friend other sean not podcast
john but other sean sean mihalek who
helps with my
how to write better uh online writing
class
he uh he recommended album from a band
called elbow
are you familiar with this band elbow no
yeah yeah like well they a new album
come out called little fictions
and it is so good i was listening to it
all weekend little fictions by elbow has
added a lot of value to my life
last weekend or yeah i was listening to
it last night and bex was making dinner
we were just hanging out and it was all
in the background it was
it was really outstanding so check out
little fictions by elbow
all right now let's move on to right
here right now it's where we get to talk
about what's going on in the lives of
the minimalists now many of you listen
to this podcast and you're like
you guys have a website too even though
we mention our website all the time
our website's really what started the
minimalists you know six over six years
ago
and we've got a bunch of new things
we've been putting up on the website new
writings of course all of our podcast
episodes go up there but
new writings are up on the website as
well and so
there's an essay recently actually i'll
just we have a list of things that have
been on the website recently so if you
subscribe to the website you already
know that
anytime a new essay or something comes
out it just shows up in your
your email inbox um every time we we
publish something new including all the
show notes they show up as well
but here are some recent examples of new
essays on
on the website there's an essay called
would you buy it again
and i'll just read this one because it's
really short but i found it to be really
powerful a lot of people got value from
it
that shirt you haven't worn in months
that box of trinkets in the garage
that closet that basement that storage
locker all brimming with stuff
what do you own that you don't enjoy
if you could start over would you buy
those items again
today if not then perhaps today
is the day to let go
one day or day one you decide
and so uh there's little pithy you know
essays very short bite-sized essays you
can share with friends and other people
they'll show up right in your inbox if
if you subscribe let's look at examples
of other things that are on the website
our critics podcast there's a um
dear critics essay that we we wrote the
love people use things wallpaper
man i've seen so many people displaying
that on social media it has been crazy
shout out to spire media all the folks
over aspire
dave especially for designing that
beautiful wallpaper which you can find
at theminimalist.com
the actual cost of owning a thing was an
essay the true cost of
a thing goes well beyond the price on
the price tag
so that was the essay that just came out
uh we also announced things like the
bost
the boston event the minimalists in
boston so if you're on the email list
you would have been the first to know
about that and be able to get the
the best seats in the house for any of
our events when we come to town
an essay called turn down the volume
with all the technological advances of
the past few decades we've become
more efficient than ever but with every
discreet bit of input
our world has grown louder and we wrote
about that
turning down the volume in the world
around us and a bunch of other stuff as
well how to start a successful blog in
2017
resolve to review which is my new year's
resolution and then
back to basics we talk about how we
spent the last six years and we sort of
look back in the
in the rear view for a moment so we can
look toward the horizon getting back to
basics this year
and uh wrote about wrote about that in
in detail
the last six years and then we wrote
about the holidays
we had you know black friday essay we
had 40 reasons to avoid
shopping on black friday uh we had
something called everything for
christmas which we gave a christmas gift
to our audience
and much much much more a bunch of free
stuff free content on our website essays
podcasts
events etc all that stuff can be found
at theminimalists.com
let me see what else is going on this is
pretty funny ryan you uh
you sold this the um our book everything
that remains just came out
on um audiobook recently and so
i was doing something for the upload for
that to work and i was on amazon i saw
there's there's like this when you go to
amazon it says like customer pictures of
this product right
and i saw this um
picture of a guy on a boat and i'm like
what
this amazon must have messed something
up so this guy left a review
of our book everything that remains and
what i found so obviously cashed in his
boatmelon rebate with our book
very few people are doing that if you
read all the way to the end there's a
mail on rebate we send you a boat
i think the guy he was just showing what
a happy life he is living well yeah
there's a picture of him on his boat
doing what he loves
exactly he said it's unique it's
priceless and it's amazing this book
changed my life and there's a picture of
him on his boat enjoying the open sea
and
that was a beautiful metaphor i mean for
me i wouldn't enjoy being on a boat
because i get seasick but this guy
is now enjoying what he loves because
this the book helped him open his eyes
so
i just wanted to say thank you to him
and thank you to anyone else who has
reviewed
the book or or the podcast or or
anything else so thanks
thank you for your support for spreading
that word um i just found i found it
comical he had a picture of him on his
boat as a
as a a customer uh testimonial so to
speak
um anyway what else is going on what
what what what what do i have here
oh um don't collect all three so finally
all three of our books
are available as audiobooks so essential
minimalism and everything that remains
everything that remains is my personal
favorite they're finally all
on audiobook but of course we don't
encourage you to collect
anything for those of you who want to
know about the distinction between our
three
books you can find that at the
minimalists.com
the word three all spelled out but um
i'll give you a brief synopsis
everything that remains the book i
recommend starting with it's sort of our
why to book it's our personal story of
of letting go it documents our five year
journey from these
suit and thai corporate guys to becoming
minimalists
and and basically what we try to do with
that book is answer the question
why have i given so much meaning to my
my material possessions
and also questions like why have i been
so discontented by the status quo
and what if everything i ever wanted
isn't what i actually
want and and so it answers those
questions in sort of the narrative
format
minimalism was the first book we wrote
but it's the second book i recommend
reading if you get past everything that
remains you want more you can dive deep
it's the what to book
so you go from the y2 to the what to it
focuses on the five values that we
that we focus on for living a more
meaningful life and it
attempts to answer the questions what is
a meaningful life who's the person i
want to become
and how will i define my success after
letting go of all my excess stuff
and our third book rounds out the the
trio the trilogy there
essential which is more of a a how-to
book it's the the best of the
minimalists
it's a collection of 150 essays that
focus on 12 distinct areas of
intentional living
from decluttering gift giving and
finances to passion
health and relationships and this book
attempts to answer the question
how would my life be better with less
and because people enjoy books
differently
all three books are available as
paperback or ebook or audiobook
and for the best experience like i said
i recommend reading them in that order
sort of going from why two to what two
to how to
is makes the most sense to me and then
of course we'll have people say but
doesn't selling a book fly in the
face of your minimalist ethos ryan
aren't the minimalists asking people to
consume more stuff
josh as one of the minimalists my life
is steeped in irony at this point
he's actually sitting in a vat of irony
right now look at all this irony
not very minimal with irony
[Laughter]
so i think it's a fair question except
books
are not consumables they are experiences
so you can consume the experience you
can own the experience
the value is not in the artifact itself
the value is in the words
so we don't want you to consume our
books we want you to experience
them right but if you do make a
everything that remains smoothie you let
us know how it tastes oh it tastes
enlightened
all right so um yeah do we want you to
purchase our books
sure only if you're willing to read them
uh yeah you can probably go to the
library and get them for free though
just so you know
yeah and do not collect them
if you're finished with the book pass it
on to someone else who can find value in
its pages in that experience right
instead of buying our books as ryan said
you can you can find them at your local
library and if your local branch doesn't
have any of our books then you can ask
them to order it most libraries
are delighted to fulfill your your
request as a local patron so
no matter the vehicle no matter what it
is whether it's our essays our podcasts
our books or our documentary we hope you
find value
in our message and above all we want to
add value to your life so however you
decide to
to experience that content we're
grateful you're here and you're giving
us your two most precious resources your
your time and your attention and we're
definitely grateful for that
last thing i have ryan is if people are
really interested in advertising on this
podcast
30 second or 60 second advertisements or
if you want a big banner ad on our
website
too bad you know what we don't do
advertisements because advertisements
suck but you can support us you can
either donate to the calls if you if
you'd like you just go to the
minimalist.com
donate or you can leave a five-star
review uh
on itunes for this podcast either one of
those will help us
spread our message ryan you got anything
else yeah they could give us
uh a hug over twitter too i like i like
i like
twitter hugs twugs twugs patent
patentpending
twigs.com uh yeah man i got i got a lot
of this stuff i'd like to give you here
take this
josh here's some voicemail comments and
tips from our listeners
hello my name is andrew molito and i'm
from baltimore maryland
hey mls i just wanted to say i love the
podcast and i wanted to share an idea
that my wife
did for my uh this past christmas um
i was asking for nothing trying to be
minimalist and trying to
kind of reduce the clutter coming into
her house
so what she ended up doing for me was
taking her name off of many many mailing
lists which
and gave that to me as a christmas gift
and i thought that was
a really awesome idea because i'm always
on her about the clutter and the waste
that comes
into via mail about a year ago i did all
of that for myself taking myself off the
mailing list
love that i don't get a bunch of
unimportant paper waste
into my house and she went ahead and
unsubscribed from
some of the more larger catalogs that
she got so i wanted to
spread that as an idea and tell you guys
thanks again for
for the podcast i love listening to it
and i love
hearing the tips and tricks that you
guys have especially that this
minimalist thing is not really a black
and white thing
and i can use the quote unquote
ingredients to kind of
make it work for my life hey guys my
name is ender goachman
i'm in minnesota up north here and i'm
just responding to
a recent podcast on criticism uh there's
a saying that i always kind of say to
myself
i do some work that involves a lot of
input from people that always
always isn't welcome and that is uh the
the quote is
to escape criticism do nothing say
nothing
be nothing and so that was very poignant
um and kind of
relates to what you guys are talking
about hey guys
this message is from steve in palm beach
gardens
florida i truly enjoy listening to your
podcast
i'm adding a ton of value to my life
through the various topics you discuss
i'm even learning new words such as
superfluous
i have a minimalism tip i would like to
share with my fellow listeners
i'm in the process of becoming a
minimalist i am constantly evaluating my
possessions
and discerning my wants for my needs as
well as questioning the value
that certain items bring to me
personally
recently i was on the verge of selling
my beloved custom
gibson es335 guitar a guitar that i
truly enjoy
and use often i was convinced that this
item
needed to go however i was still on the
fence
i was ready to depart with one of my
most prized possessions
but hesitant the reason i wanted to get
rid of this item is because i have
another electric guitar
that i also use frequently i use both of
both of these guitars often and consider
to them
to be what you all refer to as tools
as i began to clean up the guitar and
post an ad on craigslist
i began to look around at the ridiculous
amount of other items that still
occupied my home
in that moment i realized there were an
abundance of items that literally
brought me
zero value and meant much less to me
than this guitar
i soon began to truly evaluate my
possessions
after taking a few weeks to think more
on this particular item
i had i donated and trashed so many
other useless objects in the process
if i had written out a list of every
item i owned and ranked them in order of
importance to me
there would have been hundreds below
this particular
guitar i learned a valuable lesson in
this process
i was so stuck on the idea of becoming a
minimalist and become
and getting rid of things that i forgot
who i was in the process
guitars are a big part of my life so
my fellow minimalists don't get rid of
the things
that you know bring you joy get rid of
all the no-brainers
first then if you reach a point where
you realize you still do not want that
particular item
maybe you will in fact still depart from
it
but for me it was all the other crap in
my life that i needed to get rid of
first
not one of the few items that i truly
love
all right y'all that's it for this
episode if you have a question for the
minimalists give us a call
406 406-219-7839 and if you leave here
with just one message we hope it's this
there's no such thing as good debt
[Laughter]
no no no if you leave here with one
message we hope what's this love people
and use
things because the opposite never works
thanks for listening y'all
we'll see you next time
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing that's just feeding
your greed oh i bet that you'll be fine
without it
every little thing that you gotta have
every little thing that you gotta have
you gotta reach for and you gotta grab
oh i bet that you'll be fine without
[Music]
anyway
you